there are over 12,000 diseases in the
world some take years to diagnose and
treat how can doctors find insights in a
body of medical knowledge that doubles
every five years new solutions based on
IBM Watson are being developed to help
doctors analyze a patient's history
symptoms and latest medical literature
to make faster more accurate dice
hello my name is Watson let's build a
smarter planet please welcome Jason tans
New York editor wired with pasa
Chaudhary medical scientist and lead
research clinician for Watson IBM
welcome back thanks for joining us
Thanks to everyone online who's watching
from across the globe so we've just lost
a short video about Watson which I
always associated with with jeopardy as
I imagine most of us do so so talked
with dr. Chaudry a little bit about what
Watson's rule might be in the doctor's
office that's a great question i think
you know jeopardy presented as an
additional set of challenges and I think
we're eager to adapt the technology to
different industries to create solutions
that are going to have meaningful value
to people and what they're hoping to
accomplish I think with health care has
been one on once we've prioritized and I
think you know what we roughly see
Watson doing is helping people deal with
the cognitive burden of healthcare and
medicine and what do I mean by that I
think the experience of getting health
care for patients and consumers is often
overwhelming the experience of doing it
as a physician is often overwhelming to
provide I think even sub sub specialists
in their fields for instance can't
really keep up with all the things they
need to read just to practice medicine
you know the best way that they can so
we envision Watson is a model for
cognitive computing where it's providing
support to people for the different
kinds of reasoning tasks that they have
to engage in to accomplish their work
efficiently there's nothing roughly
serves an outline you know that's part
of what we're envisioning here how do we
reduce the cognitive burden on people
and as they seek provide medical care so
it's to help parse the deluge of
information that keeps coming in every
day with new studies and the latest
research but also
to help fit a patient into a broader
sort of network of information is that
is that right yeah that's exactly that's
exactly right think it's a good way of
thinking about it I think you know we
think about models like personalized
medicine which we've discussed a lot
here it's that's the future it's partly
the question here is how do we
operationalize that we put into practice
so if we have all these different
dimensions of data about an individual
we want to provide them with the best
care possible how do we match say the
different characteristics they have
personal medical things like that their
preferences with you know a set of
knowledge and information which is going
to define what the best thing to do for
them is and I think it's very difficult
to do that just do human cognitive
capacity alone right and then we're
entering an age in which data is more
important than ever you know obviously
we've talked a lot about quality based
care as opposed fee-for-service things
like that talk about what what some of
the new data challenges are that we're
going to be facing as we move to this
new model of medicine sure I think
there's just tremendous change in virus
vibrancy across healthcare right now I
think you know the way it's orient is
changing rapidly we're moving to more
consumer and patient-centered model
we're focusing more on health rather
than disease the practice medicine is
changing we're moving to more
personalization and predictive medicine
the flip side we're developing a much
broader base for things like primary
care to enhance wellness and prevention
the way medicine is in health care paid
for the business models that are
supporting them are changing rapidly the
way science is being practiced things
like adaptive clinical trials for
example there's a great deal of
innovation there as well and I think the
thing that brings many of these threads
together is the importance of data and
knowledge and extracting value from that
data and I think that's sort of one of
the fundamental foundations that's being
put in place for the future of health
healthcare and medicine and we were
talking about stage about some of the
risks of a data of a purely data-driven
model that you know a for instance if
you are basing payment on statistics
right you know readmission rates or what
have you that
Dana had better be high-quality right so
we've all had the experience of working
with some piece of enterprise software
that required you to enter you know
various numbers and various boxes and
sometimes they give a full picture and
sometimes they don't talking about how
you guys are thinking about that
challenge and what was it might
represent in that regard yeah it's a
very good question i think when you have
these really complicated issues you know
one of the ways to think about data and
uses to think about there's many
different dimensions of the problem and
different kinds of data are going to
address different dimensions so just
take for example one of the areas i
think we really need to have a much
better understanding of to provide more
humane care is patient experience what
is it like to receive medical care what
does it like to be inside of the
healthcare system what are your
priorities and goals and I think that's
for example a set of activities which is
really difficult to put into you know
pick lists or it's really difficult to
kind of use structured data to get at
that you know a lot of the humane
aspects of medicine are related to
narrative features in medicine I think
one of the things we're hopeful about
Watson is that we can capture you know
some of these dimensions through natural
language and allow people to interact
with technology in ways which are more
organic to them so give me an example of
what that might look like if I'm trying
to figure out what a patient experience
in my hospital is like how would I be
able to determine that now and how might
I be able to determine that using
something like watching that's a good
example I think there's going to be a
couple different levels that but just as
immediate example a lot of patient
experience right now for say when
someone's in the hospital is captured by
nursing notes and those are generally
handwritten notes and the nurses make a
bunch of observations during their shift
in general that data isn't really
extensively used it's very common that
physicians just not at the time or
patience to read through it it's in
places which aren't convenient access
it's all narrative so it doesn't
necessarily pop up into different fields
in electronic health record right so
it's not easy to quantify it's not easy
to quantify and I think bringing new
kinds of techniques new kinds of
technologies particularly with respect
to this kind of
unstructured narrative data is going to
provide new avenues to mind that type of
experience and try to get more
understanding and insight of what it's
like when you know someone comes in and
doesn't allow you to sleep or things
like that think important things on
improving the performance and
productivity the health care system so
in other words if you have if you're
using something like natural language
processing you can extract information
from those notes rather than half of
them have to be converted into data you
could say oh I see that this person
didn't sleep for the last six nights or
something because that was in the notes
it wasn't because somebody went through
and tick the box that said exactly you
know I think it is just an example but
it's just some one of the things that
personally from a clinical point of view
comes to mind quite a bit when I think
about sort of what does the future going
to look like mm-hmm and I think
understanding these dimensions of
patient experience really are important
I think I was one of the nice challenges
of Jeopardy you know language is so
nuanced and the kinds of things that are
asked in jeopardy are quite difficult to
interpret so it created a really
concrete set of challenges that we've
been able to now sort of extend and
start applying to the domain of medicine
alright so let's pull back the lens a
little bit i mean we talked a little bit
about the patient doctor experience how
can hospitals use unstructured data to
improve their operations again we're
entering an age in which quality of care
is becoming an important metric but
figuring out how to represent that
metric is its own kind of challenged so
so talk to me a little bit about how
technologies like Watson can be used to
help hospitals understand what they're
doing well and maybe what they're not
doing so well that's again another
really difficult and good question I
think again a lot of this is you know
the way physicians in particular and
nurses and healthcare professions tend
to document information record it for
themselves tends to be in very
unstructured way you might be in clinic
different kinds of clinical notes and I
think that's sort of the way people are
custom to working and what the way that
feels more comfortable to them it's a
lot of the insight that's involved in
the care activity experience for
providers and professionals Israel is in
capturing these kinds
notes I think baa be able to extract
information from that kind of data
processing ways where you can draw
insight and organize the knowledge
involved with it I think it's going to
be really important to what we can do in
the flexibility we can create perhaps
care professionals in the future and as
compensation becomes tied to quality of
care we talked a little bit about this
backstage that if you're talking about
structured data like for instance with
the u.s. News & World Report's college
rankings right you find some of the
schools essentially teaching to the test
right there they're trying to maximize
the kind of data that they can report
how so it sounds like unstructured data
may allow a way out of that kind of
conundrum I think it's going to be
really important because again a lot of
these things we're trying to measure
like you think measurement
quantification data for all these
recurring themes about change in health
care they're trying to get at really
complex ideas that are going on in
people's lives complex things people are
doing in their own work so the more
dimensions of that we can capture the
better off we're going to be I think
that's going to help us avoid things
like teaching to the test because you
can look at not just one single metric
that kept might capture one dimension of
an issue but many of them I think many
of those are going to be in unstructured
data and combining both structured and
unstructured data I think it's going to
be important for the future so can you
give me an example of what that might
what that might look like it's done it's
done what if done right sure so right
now say for someone with diabetes one of
the common ways we look to collect data
or measure and quantify the kinds of
care that they're getting is to
ascertain whether or not someone's had
their feet checked right so that's the
one of the really most common quality
metrics and sources of data related to
diabetes care has a physician check this
patients fee that's an important thing
to do but the entire sort of universe of
things or the ways ways we want to treat
people with diabetes far exceed you know
these kinds of particular narrow metrics
I can check someone steep that doesn't
mean I've treated
you mainly right that doesn't mean I've
understood the complexity of what it's
like to take insulin for them or to try
to deal with low blood sugar as it
happens and these are I think really
complex ideas but these are really i
think what attunes the dynamics of
someone's life when they have that kind
of chronic condition I think gaining
insight into that is it going to be
really important to fundamentally
changing the way we practice medicine
and the way people receive care and to
pull back the lens even further one of
the great challenges we're facing as a
country is how to bend the cost curve
how to make how to make medical care
more affordable generally have is that
the kind of thing that it can be aided
by the sort of technology as well yeah
yeah i think that there's just
tremendous promise for learning from
data at large you know and the impact
that can have on doing things like
making that it's a more productive
making health care more efficient
bending the cost curve as you said and
having data and information at hand is
going to be foundational to that and
again these you know types of approaches
with unstructured data and things like
notes you know hopefully images in the
future things like that are going to be
really i think critical to doing that
kind of thing and achieving the kind of
endpoints that we're hoping to so again
maybe walk me through what itwhat itwhat
a doctor would go through and the
hospital would go through you know from
the time the patient comes in how is my
practice going to change in the world of
unstructured data that using that is an
assistant that's a that's a great
question so you know one of the things
we're working on right now I think with
with movement towards more personalized
medicine it's getting harder hard to to
pick which is the best pathway for care
for a particular patient that's becoming
a real challenge you know in the future
if we r you know understanding patience
potentially hundreds and hundreds of
different dimensions or features of
what's involved in their sort of
demographics or their medical care we're
going to wind up we're not with one
treatment but particular many many
treatments for people with particular
sets of conditions
how to choose between one pathway or
another is really difficult and I think
we're going to have to create a whole
new cadre of cognitive support and
cognitive support tools for this type of
activity so the patient may come in they
may have a certain genomic profile may
have a certain you know the tablet ohmic
profile these are all different kinds of
features there can have different
preferences and goals so there I think
you can see that some of these things
are going to involve very you know
discrete structured data things like you
know their genomic information right but
you know what their preference is what
their goals are for their care how they
choose to make trade-offs what they're
prioritizing all those things I think
are really rich complex and what really
sort of shape people's lives I think
being able to bring those things
together and then pick well for this
person based on their characteristics
and their preferences what's the you
know kwang-ho optimal thing to do for
them that becomes a real possibility in
the future mm-hmm great well amazingly
we were already out of time when we fast
but thanks for a fascinating talk thank
you